[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's good hey everybody uh it's me
Kevin Smith welcome to spod Castle
Cinemas where the movies come to play
kids
foreign
event in store for you uh with uh an
absolute uh legend of the Arts and I
dare say probably the richest man who
ever came to this movie theater
uh we'll try to get money out of him
before the night's over
uh the uh just a little heads up for
some future events and whatnot I'd be a
terrible theater co-owner if I didn't uh
pimp out the next few events we're doing
uh one week from Friday kids is the
opening of a black panther wakanda
forever so we will yes [ __ ] it hey
Marvel they need your help
um
we will of course be screening the movie
uh for everybody in terms of general
admission but we will also be holding
our very first merry Marvel movie
Society screening so here on forward uh
now that like it's small Castle Cinemas
every time a Marvel movie opens I'm a
huge Marvel movie fan we will have a
merry Marvel movie Society screening uh
comes with comics and and free [ __ ] and
whatnot but more importantly
um I intro the movie and then we watch
the movie and then I do a q a for the
movie afterwards for a movie I had
nothing to do with
we just get to geek out about Marvel
together and [ __ ] so Ryan coogler the
director won't be here Kevin Smith the
director
not of wakanda forever will be here
taking your question so uh that will be
uh a week from Friday
um when Black Panther opens up and then
this is the event I'm very excited about
that but
um there's something we're doing on
Black Friday uh which is called the uh
first annual Black Friday Zach and
mirathon
um now you're like oh my God we're gonna
show Zac and Miri all day long no that's
not it
so so America it's porn 24 7.
basically it would just hook up Pornhub
more like the new Zack and Mary
um no what we're doing is uh so you all
know a marathon is 26 miles that's what
makes marathon and marathons 26 miles so
the Zach and marathon is 26 Isles as you
can see we got an aisle here and an
aisle here we're gonna have 13 separate
sprinting races from here to the back of
the theater top three prizes top top
three times when gold silver and bronze
and then we just watched the movie
so no no everyone does not have to
participate in [ __ ] uh and if you
participate you'll be signing a [ __ ]
waiver believe me because if you break
your leg that's your [ __ ] fault
um so uh if you're gonna come and you're
like [ __ ] yeah I want to race and [ __ ]
um you're gonna have to sign up come a
little bit early and sign up but we're
just the rest of us are going to sit
around and watch some Athletics and then
watch a movie about Falcon
um that's that's what life at smog
Castle Cinemas will be like from here
going forward uh tonight kids uh was an
evening that was born many years ago far
from here uh in a country called
Switzerland at the new chatel film
festival that is where I met uh
tonight's guest
um who I'm gonna be honest with you
right now
um is going to be a formidable
guest for me to speak with because uh
from the moment I met him and then I've
I've haven't seen him again until
tonight but I remembered very clearly
from our meeting uh in new chateau
I think I may have found a [ __ ]
who talks more than me
oh my God and not only is he talking
more than me it's all [ __ ] rich and
interesting and I never forgot we were
in [ __ ] Switzerland at a film
festival they were honoring uh Red State
I think it was but for me that whole
[ __ ] Festival was talking to
tonight's guest and at the time I wasn't
even deeply familiar with the piece of
work that everybody [ __ ] knows I
hadn't watched Game of Thrones yet Jason
Muse had bugged me for two years
straight he's like you gotta [ __ ]
watch this
I was like why he goes so many dicks in
this show
I was like a bunch of [ __ ] he goes
no literally just dicks hanging out I
was like I thought it was about swords
he's going and fleshy swords as well
that was his whole pitch on Game of
Thrones watch it for the dicks so I
didn't catch up with it for a couple
seasons and by the time I caught up with
it it was after I met our guest in new
chatel and I was home and I was like oh
you know what he was cool I love talking
to him maybe I'll watch that show and
then [ __ ] fell in love with it until
the Red Wedding and then was [ __ ]
horrified
and then kept watching of course so
um tonight we're going to talk about of
course we'll touch on uh the works that
have made him incredibly world renowned
as well as incredibly [ __ ] wealthy
man owns trains we'll talk about that
later
um but this is a story that begins in
fandom that's why I want you to keep in
your heads tonight ladies and gentlemen
we're gonna sit here and we're gonna
talk to somebody who has created the pop
culture that we have enjoyed for the
last like 10 years we're living in his
[ __ ] dreams or anybody in this room
don't know what Westeros is at this
point
and the rest of the world at this point
knows what Westeros is thanks to that TV
show that mythology was born in the
brain of a kid born and raised in New
Jersey
[Applause]
so as we sit here and chit chat tonight
and as you listen to story after Story
remember that like
this guy while being an insanely
talented Legend and an icon
shares something you know almost on the
DNA level with mostly everybody in this
[ __ ] room man we're from the same
[ __ ] place and that dude dreamed of a
whole [ __ ] different place he was
from Bayonne which must be the model for
Westeros
um but
um everybody no matter what they do in
this world uh gravitates there
from a position of fandom in order to be
it you have to see it first so
ultimately tonight is is going to be a
story of fandom and I'm going to read
you something right now
that goes back oh [ __ ] to the 60s this
may be
some of the first published work of our
guests tonight we'll find out this was a
letter that was written to Marvel Comics
uh back in I guess 1963-64 after
issue seven number seven
of the Fantastic Four so there'd only
been six previous issues of the
Fantastic Four
um or rather eight probably and this was
oh I'm sorry 18. this is Fantastic Four
number 17. only been 16 prior issues
then
this letter was written based on this
issue and it goes like this deer Stan
and Jack and of course we're talking
about Stan Lee a dude I was lucky enough
to know and the great Jack Kirby uh the
two two of the greatest fathers of the
Marvel Universe
uh Dear Stan and Jack Fantastic Four
number 17 was greater than great even
now I sit in awe of it trying to do the
impossible that is describe it it was
absolutely stupendous the ultimate
utmost I cannot fathom how you could fit
so much action into so few pages that
will live forever as one of the greatest
Fantastic Four Comics ever printed Ergo
as one of the greatest of all comics in
what other comic mag could you see
things like a hero falling down a
manhole a heroine mistaking a toy
inventor for a criminal and the
president of the USA leaving a
conference that may determine the fate
of the world to put his daughter to bed
the Epic story spectacular and exciting
as it is is not all that made this mag
so great the letter column was Top Notch
too this motherfucker's such a nerd he
was praising the letter column
um the letter column was top-notch too I
nearly died when I saw Paul gambasini's
letter you've really made him change his
tune that letter was a far cry from the
one printed in Fantastic Four number
nine then there's your cover I mean
that's deep Cuts bro
like to know the story of the comic to
know these characters great but this guy
memorized the letters that other people
wrote he was like remember that one
[ __ ] from episode from issue nine he
sure [ __ ] came around yeah
then there's your cover boast the
world's greatest comic magazine all in
caps brilliant you were just about the
world's worst mag when you started but
you set yourself an ideal and by gumbo
you achieved it more than achieved it in
fact why if you were only half as good
as you are now you'd still be the
world's best mag George R only one r at
those days
not rich enough for the second [ __ ] r
George R Martin 35 East First Street
Bayonne New Jersey to which they wrote
back we might as well quit while we're
ahead thanks for your kind words George
and now it's time for our favorite
department where we talk to you straight
from the shoulder and they just [ __ ]
moved on
thanks for the kind words George they
had no idea that the young fan who was
writing them a letter would create his
own mythology that would stand shoulder
to shoulder with Marvel's mythology in
our current pop culture landscape uh
ladies and gentlemen
him being here brings our house more
honor than this house can possibly bear
welcome back to New Jersey bayonne's
George R.R Martin
[Applause]
um okay
that letter that we just heard
um is that your first published work
ever
um
well-defined published uh I think I
might have had things in the high school
newspaper before that but uh yeah that
was the first thing that beyond the
confines of uh of Bayonne now I assume
it was a letter from Fantastic Four
number 20. I couldn't quite hear 17
number 17 is the one you wrote in on
well you wrote yeah from Fantastic 420
and you're writing about it about 17 yes
that was the first one I did
subsequently have a number of other
letters published in other Marvel Comics
other Fantastic Fours Avengers
I might have been in a Spider-Man or two
let me ask you this think back to those
moments when your letters got published
were you like it will never get better
than this
um
it was pretty exciting yeah that was
made me a letter hack which they called
it back then and also
curiously changed my life in in some
ways I mean because if you notice when
he read the letter at the end in those
days they printed your full address
so
I started to stand by the [ __ ] you said
man it's not like today on Twitter where
you just say some [ __ ] and be anonymous
well that's true yes but I Comics fandom
comic book fandom was just starting
around then
I mean
science fiction fandom goes all the way
back to the 1920s actually and there'd
always been comic fans within science
fiction fandom but in back then in the
early 60s very early 60s comic book
fandom was splitting off from science
fiction fandom
and they were publishing their own fan
scenes do any of you know what a fan
scene is you know that I don't even know
what a a mimeograph machine is
or a ditto machine
ditto you don't know what that is it's
fancies with these amateur magazines put
out by fans that had a combination of
fan art
and fan
fiction and non-fiction articles
discussing the comics they usually sold
for like a quarter
and they were produced either by a
mimeograph machine which you type on a
stencil and then you run it through this
drum and it produces a number or
this process called ditto which involved
a tray and like gelatin and there was a
master and you could
you could produce on a ditto machine
like 20 30 copies of whatever you uh
were producing and then it faded it was
always purple but the fans who many of
whom were high school kids like me were
publishing these fanzines and when my
letter came out they started mailing it
to me oh look and I started getting
these weird ass fanzines in the mail
and some were better than others
um
and some of them they had articles in
them and they had fiction in them not
and I want to be clear here because I
I've people have
people have
criticized me before here because I
don't like what is today called fan
fiction and does any of you know what
fan fiction is it's basically copyright
infringement
where you you take some character that
you like and you write stories about
them that are not part of it and I don't
like that
um
but I wrote fan fiction for the fanzines
but the term was defined differently in
those days fan fiction was just fiction
written by fans we didn't steal Superman
or Batman or at a Fantastic Four or
write stories about them we created our
own characters and these early fanzines
had fiction in them some of which
honestly
was really bad
really bad and that's good for me it was
good for me because
reading it led me to set these these
words that fundamentally changed my life
and I think many aspiring writers say
these words at some point which is where
you're reading and you say
even I could do better than that
and you write stories and you send them
orphan they accept them and yes I could
do better than that the people liked my
stories and they wrote I didn't get paid
anything you know they if I was lucky I
got a free copy to fanzine but um
suddenly I was writing stories about
manta ray and garazan the mechanical
Warrior and the white Raider and all
these other heroes superheroes that I
was creating for these comic fanzines
and uh
people like them and that encouraged me
to do more of them all because of that
uh
letter in Fantastic Four and they
started sending me to Fan scenes
otherwise who knows if I would have
found them or they would have found me
now that letter you told me too when we
were talking about the first time also
LED
other people to reach out to you other
fans who were like didn't somebody write
you a letter to be like I liked your
letter
yes I got a variety you know some people
like my letter and some people sent me
their fan jeans and I started I started
to send away money for these fanzines
too
which many of them cost a quarter
I didn't have you know I was like 12
years old I didn't have a checking
account so if I wanted to buy anything I
actually had to send a quarter through
the mail and you didn't want the quarter
bouncing around inside the envelope so
you Scotch taped it to an index card
and they were called in in Phantom
sticky quarters and if you published a
fan scene you've got a lot of sticky
quarters because the Scotch tape left
the thing on it so I sent away to Sticky
quarters and I got more and more
fanzines and in the back of it sometimes
besides the stories and the articles
there would be
um ads for people who were selling comic
books and you know back issues and
things like that and uh I
I discovered the Fantastic Four
with Issue Number Four it suddenly
appeared I'd never heard of this company
before I'd you know marvel they weren't
even called Marvel then they didn't have
a name
um and who the hell these Heroes they
didn't have costumes but they looked
interesting and then I had to find
issues one through three and the only
way to do that was there were no comic
book shops you had a hope that someone
would be selling them in the back and I
also
was reading the DC Comics so one of the
big changes in my life is my my dear
friend Howard Waldrop who uh Howard
lives in Texas he lived in Texas then I
lived in Bayonne
but we started corresponding
because I bought a comic book from him
he was selling Brave and bull number 28
for 25 cents and uh I bought it he
figured he he made a great bargain there
because uh you know he paid a dime for
it and he got to sell it for 25 cents
that was a huge profit
uh of course you know he spent a quarter
but I still have Brave and bow number 28
and it's worth like 50 000 now
[Laughter]
introduction of the Justice League
[Laughter]
did he spent that quarter though he did
he did he just went to town on it yeah
but Howard was a writer himself and he's
a great great writer a winner of many
awards and uh I'm making some movies now
of some of his classic short stories he
still lives in Texas and I still don't
uh
but you started as pen pal you start
corresponding because of the sale and
stuff John F Kennedy was in the white
house that's how long ago we started a
corresponding and maintained a
friendship all that time yeah I finally
met him in 72 and uh at a science
fiction convention
um that's the first time we were
actually uh you know face to face with
each other so yeah tell me about
fandom because it didn't exist when you
were a kid you you kind of laid the
track for it like do you remember going
to a comic book show well a science
fiction fandom had existed for a long
time but Comics fandom was beginning
just then to to spin off
from it
and um
they were just having their own
conventions and I I am the original
comic book fan in that way
first comic book exclusively comic book
convention ever held was 1964 New York
City
um
it was held it was one day
held in like a union hall the the
working men's hall or something for one
day in one room a room significantly
smaller than this Auditorium where there
were like three guys in the back who
were selling Comics out of cardboard
boxes and a bunch of folding chairs and
a little Podium where people talk but
when they started advertising this in
the fan scenes
I was the first one to send in my dollar
fifty of course the dollar fifty to go I
said to my dollar fifty so I was member
number one and I I took the bus from
Bayonne over to New York City and I
attended that comic book convention met
a bunch of fans the the really cool
thing about well
um there were a number of artists and
writers who came in and talked
um most of them I didn't know they were
older from older strips and all that
fabulous flow Steinberg was one of the
big guests most of you are looking at me
blankly he was Stanley's secretary but
he was always talking about her in the
Marvel Comics fabulous flow so we didn't
actually get Stan Lee but we got
fabulous flow and
we also got Steve ditko
um
Steve ditko for the ignorant is the
co-father of Spider-Man
uh the spider Stan Lee and Steve didco
great Spider-Man Steve ditko also
co-created Dr Strange over at uh
Charlton he did the question which is
now a DC character he's an absolute
[ __ ] Legend he went to the show he
went to the show I think it was the only
one he ever went to we must have scared
the hell out of him because he
he never went back but he was just very
quiet he did not give a speech but he
was just there and I got to talk to him
and and say
no Mr ditko I really liked your work and
he was very nice and I said I like Dr
Strange best and he said so did he that
doctor strange was his favorite to draw
but I don't know but he never he never
went back and of course from that that
little convention in uh
in the working man's Hall in Greenwich
Village uh
now they get 150 000 people every year
at the San Diego Comic Con and I think
almost as much as the New York Comic-Con
so the times have definitely changed but
uh little did we know what was uh what
was being born then how many people in
your family in Bayonne when you were
growing up
um well I'm I have two sisters so it was
my mother and father and me and my two
sisters what did Mom and Dad do well my
father was a longshoreman
and um my mother was uh when I was very
young she was a housewife she stayed
home and took care of the kids later she
got a factory job at uh Maidenform which
had a big Factory in Bayonne first uh on
the assembly line and later she was uh
you know promoted to uh management to an
inspector so you know if any of you
in the 60s or border Maidenform bra and
that's been inspected by number seven it
might have been her
what what did your sisters do I'm asking
because where's the writing come from
who introduces you to the notion of
hey you could create things you could
write you don't have to just read you
could also write I I really have no idea
I think I may be a mutant
um a radioactive mutant or something uh
my mother had had books around the house
um I don't think my father ever ever
read a book that he didn't have to read
for school
um
this but I've been making up stories
since
this as long as I can remember longer
than I can remember and because I am a
pack rat and and never throw basically
anything away uh you know I would you
would probably be seeing me on an
episode of Hoarders
if not for the fact that I've made a
fair amount of money so I can keep
buying additional houses
to keep my my stuff in
um not hoarding if you spread it out
that's right
um
so I still have some of these weird ass
things that I wrote when I was little
I have a in one of those black and white
school books you know with the pebbled
black and white color purple composition
yeah yeah yeah I I wrote an encyclopedia
of space
in which I
I drew I drew planets and then I wrote
in Block printing benuth what was on
that planet you know I did did not have
the uh
artistic talent of a Jack Kirby or Steve
ditko nor did I know how to use one of
those things to make a circle so I just
sort of Drew a circle freehand and my
planets were kind of lumpy but I you
know colored Mars red and uh you know
put rings around Saturn and then I would
write below you know Mars is the red
planet and it has martians and but of
course there were nine planets back then
that was before Neil deGrasse Titan uh
Neil deGrasse Tyson kicked Pluto out so
I had the nine planets but I had a lot
more pages so then I started inventing
planets from from the TV shows that I
was watching like a Flash Gordon and
Rocky Jones and inventing
my own planets which had you know
names that seem to have no vowels in
them names with large numbers of
consonants and x's and all that but uh I
know I had to pronounce these planets
but I invented you know this planet is
full of plant people and uh on this
planet they eat each other you know
whatever it is you know inventing this
stuff but it's
I
I did that I must have been I don't know
five six pretty young you're [ __ ]
World building at five years old who are
you the Lord himself yeah
and I had a
we lived in the projects we didn't have
much money we lived in a federal housing
project on First Street in Bayonne and
you were not allowed to have uh dogs or
cats in the projects but of course I was
a kid I wanted a pet so I got Turtles
Dime Store Turtles that you bought at
Woolworths or Kresge and they came in
these little plastic bowls that were
half water and half gravel with a fake
palm tree in the middle and uh
so happened you could fit two of those
bowls side by side in the courtyard of
this uh
toy castle that I had on so
I put the turtles
Bowls in the toy castle
and then I decided that since they lived
in a castle they were all Kings and
knights and other medieval things like I
saw on TV in Robin Hood and King Arthur
shows
the thing about those Dime Store Turtles
though if any of you have ever had them
is they they died pretty easily
it only cost 15 cents or something like
that and and they'd give you the turtle
food to feed them I don't know it was
the healthiest food you know but you'd
sprinkle it in and they'd eat it and
like a month later they'd be dead
um
sometimes one of them escaped and would
turn up six months later all shriveled
up onto the refrigerator uh
but I was very upset that my turtles
kept dying and and then I said well why
are they dying I'm giving them an
eternal food they have the water and I
decided that they were killing each
other to compete for the turtle Throne
so so the first Game of Thrones
was all about turtles
killing each other and stabbing each
other and I started writing stories
about that too so Turtle Castle is a
precursor that I may return to one of
these days
it'll be just like Game of Thrones but
with turtles
the um the
since you were writing in letters to
comic books and then started writing
uh fan fiction uh that that version of
fan fiction for zines when did you start
thinking this could be a job I could do
this for a living nobody in your world
wrote for a living or were in the arts
for a living were they
nope nope so then why did you think that
it was a viable
gig
well
um
that's a good question I'm not sure I I
know there was a certain point
when I was in kindergarten I got an
award for a a drawing I made of a cowboy
and a horse and and that made me think
maybe I could be a cartoonist
but
I actually couldn't draw uh I don't know
why they gave me the Art Award maybe
everybody else was even worse than me
but uh I had a lot of details on that
and I think my mother explained well you
drew the saddle and the and the rains
and all that and and so maybe that was
it
I love science fiction even as a kid
but for a time when I was a kid I
thought I wanted to be a space man
I wanted to do it not write about it
um and we did not have of course as you
can see I'm I mean really really really
old
um I lived in a different era and we
didn't even have the word astronaut that
came in with the Mercury Seven later
they invented that word we were Space
men I wanted to be a space man
maybe a Space Ranger like Rocky Jones my
favorite show other kids wanted to be
Cowboys or cops or something like that
or or what their father did some of them
had you know fathers who I I knew not
for a minute did I ever want to be a
longshoreman like my father uh and and
go down the docks and unload ships all
day I I saw what that said to him when
he came back
um
uh
but at some point I I guess I realized I
I didn't I'm not going to be a Spaceman
or an astronaut when I could write
stories about space men and astronauts
and superheroes you know when the comics
came along so I started doing all of
that even then I didn't know if I could
make a living from it
um
I remember I think I was in high school
one year
um and I was playing with the idea of
writing fiction and the the
English professor said Okay I want all
of you to research what you think your
job will be when you're grown up
and come back and uh so I researched
fiction writing
and
now mind you this was in
like 1963.
but I researched fiction writing and
discovered the average fiction writer in
America made twelve hundred dollars a
year from writing fiction even in 1963
you could not live on twelve hundred
dollars a year I knew that wasn't going
to work so I better do uh something else
but I was good at English and stuff so
I went to when I got to college I
majored in journalism okay I'm good at
I'm good at words I'm good at writing so
I'll write there were a number of
Science Fiction writers in the history
of the genre who had been journalists
worked in a newspaper during the day and
then weekends and nights wrote wrote
their science fiction stories and I kind
of thought that would be my my path
um
what was the first thing then that you
got published that you were paid to to
write how old were you
um I was in college
um
I wrote uh you know by the time I went
to college it was more settled that I
wanted to be
maybe not a full-time professional
writer but I wanted to be a professional
writer in some sense
so I started uh obviously I took all my
required journalism courses
but I also took um
courses in creative writing where I
could write short stories and then then
I could send out those short stories and
maybe maybe sell them and I was clever
enough that I would sneak in writing
short stories even for courses that
weren't about short stories like I was
taking a Course once in Scandinavian
history
I always liked history too and we were
supposed to do a big term paper
and I approached a professor
and said how about instead of a term
paper I write um
some historical fiction about
Scandinavian history I'll write a viking
story or something and he said oh that
sounds interesting he was a fairly cool
guy so he
he did that and and that was important
because uh I think it was my sophomore
year so I wrote a story
about the uh the Russo Finnish war of
1808 not a popular subject
and the surrender of the great Fortress
of surveyaborg and I wrote it as
historical fiction I got an A which was
good but not only that but the professor
liked the story so much that he sent it
out
to a professional magazine
an academic magazine called the American
Scandinavian review
which rejected it
but that was my first rejection slip
from a professional magazine most people
think it would be a science fiction
magazine no my first rejection strip was
from American Scandinavian review
and you know then I tried to sell the
story My I said oh this didn't hurt too
much I got a rejection slip but okay
they I'll try sending it elsewhere but I
discovered as I sent it out to you know
I bought like writer's Marketplace and
looking through the addresses and
whatever he pays and I'm sending out my
story to like Argosy and Esquire and The
New Yorker and Playboy none of whom were
really interested in the Russia Finnish
war of 1808.
so I got more rejection slips but once I
had kind of lost my rejection slip
virginity there
um I started sending out some of my
other stories and eventually one of them
sold to a Galaxy magazine the hero 1971.
that was my first uh well I sold it in
70. it appeared in 71.
what was the at that point where you're
like oh my God it'll never get better
than this or is that like you going all
right that's the first one many more to
go
yeah I I
it was pretty exciting I mean I went
I was living in Chicago at the time and
uh I didn't have a car but I had a
friend who had a car so I made him drive
me all around Chicago buying up copies
of that issue of the Galaxy because each
individual news stand only would have
one or two and I wanted more copies to
give to people and impress them so
um but that was pretty exciting that day
and they paid me 94 dollars which was
you know
significant amount of money and
1970 94.
um
and then I sold another one the next
year and I sold
more after that
I still couldn't make a living I mean
for the first first 10 years or so of my
career I was uh not
I I was writing I was publishing I was
being nominated for awards winning some
awards losing more
but um
it was a supplement to my income I had
to do a day job
um
to pay my share the rent and to pay the
mortgage and all that it wasn't until
1979 the end of 79 that I Ruled The Dice
and said okay I'm gonna I'm doing pretty
well now let's see if I can make it full
time as a writer
let's talk about writing for a second uh
people ask me from time to time like
what's your schedule you sit down how do
you do it for people that have never
done it and they're like that sounds fun
I would like to make stuff up as well
what is what's the Do you have a
schedule or I when people ask me I tell
them like you can't stop me from writing
when I want to write something because
it's just Joy like I'd rather be writing
than doing anything out somebody was
just like yeah right you'd rather write
than [ __ ] I was like yeah that's what
makes me an artist [ __ ] yeah
um so I don't know that go that far
that's that's an extreme uh sentiment
there you're like look winter ain't the
only thing coming in my house
foreign
how do you go about it do you like uh
you and I'm talking about the early days
not now did you like I'm gonna set aside
time especially in a world where you had
a job most people maybe listen would be
people who are like oh I would like to
do that but I also have a job how did
you balance real life and fantasy
well it's it's been difficult and and
the answer to that really varies as to
what time uh
in my life you're talking about and what
what was my my position and my
obligations and my living situation at
that particular time
um
I I have friends uh
who uh I occasionally hate because they
have this gift who can write anywhere
and any time I have friends who write uh
you know four pages a day no matter
where they are they they if they're
traveling they write four pages on the
airplane if they're in a hotel they
write four pages there they are four
pages every day 365 days a year they
write they write they write they can
turn it on they can turn it off I have
friends who can juggle multiple projects
at one time uh I have a one a
screenwriter friend dear friend back in
New Mexico where I live she can work on
a a novel in the morning and a
screenplay in the afternoon and a short
story in the evening three different
projects in one day she works on all of
them
I can't do any of that [ __ ]
when I'm writing when it's working for
me I don't want to be disturbed I can't
write I have tried I cannot write on
trains ships
airplanes I cannot write in weird-ass
hotel rooms
I I even can't write at home if I'm
going to be interrupted I want to be
left alone
just me and uh computer these days or
the typewriter in the old days and don't
bother me and uh
um it's always been that way and I can't
say even that writing is a Joys there
are joyful days when
you know when it really comes alive and
the characters are coming alive in the
scene and the words are pouring out of
you
feels good but they're they're not a lot
of those days there were also days
where it's
hard
and you know and I sit down and I read
what I wrote yesterday and
this is [ __ ] why am I pretending I can
do this this is terrible and I wind up
rewriting the whole thing and uh you
know and I do that for several days and
then I go to my wife and say
where's my talent what did you do with
my talent did you put it somewhere else
I can't find it anymore but then smart
man blames his wife just like that yeah
then I have a good day
um so
there's usually a rush I haven't felt
this in a long time because
as some of you may know a song of Isis
fire is not finished I have two more
books to write
but we weren't going to talk about that
by the way I I promise this would be the
one place that people weren't going to
ask about that book but I'll tell you
man everyone gets on your dick about
finishing the book I say this proves
what an amazing lover you must be
because you you make [ __ ] last George
like you're just edging us all with that
last book
I like that good explanation yeah
um tell Colbert that [ __ ]
no when
when I'm writing a short story which I
did predominantly when I started or even
a novellator novella and eventually I
got onto novels there there comes a
point
where the end is in sight you know where
where I've crested and suddenly I I pick
up speed or historically I did this I'm
talking now 70s the 80s and 90s maybe
I've been writing like a page and a half
a day but suddenly I find I'm writing
three pages today I'm running four pages
a day and God at that last day I wrote
10 pages and they're pretty damn good
and then I get the right the end and
that's the climax
um but when you're writing a novel it it
doesn't come quite as often and when
you're writing this gigantic seven
volume kind of thing
uh I really want to get to that point
where I can finish it and it'll be done
and God that will feel good for at least
a day until I reread it the next day and
decide this whole shame but yeah
um
so you know in
there are writers who love the simple
Act of writing and there are other
writers and I probably forewarn this who
love having written
um it's great when it's done and when
it's not done you know you struggle with
whether you can ever really
really do it
one of the things back in high school
and grade school when I was writing my
space encyclopedia and Turtle Castle and
all that and even a little later that
when I was writing stories
is a lot of them were not never finished
um
because
I don't know you you go through this
in your head you can see the story you
know what the story is and and God it's
it's beautiful it's like a platonic
ideal it's a shimmering wonderful story
and it's moving as poetic and it's true
and it's going to be The Greatest Story
Ever Told and then you sit down there
with the typewriter and you're trying to
write it and it's not as good as it was
in your head and you're struggling with
it and you know I would get like 10
pages into one of these stories and it
just seems worse and worse and then I'd
get a different idea for story which
would be shimmering and beautiful and
poetic and I would put the first story
aside and I'd start writing a second
story and then I had abandon that too
after a point
I'm going way back to my childhood with
you know to my very early days with that
but then I bought a um a book of
interviews with famous science fiction
writers and all that and there was a
piece by Robert a Heinlein in there
and uh he had his uh I think four rules
five rules for being a successful writer
and his first rule was you must write
which seems pretty basic but
I meet a lot of people who want to be
writers but they never get around to
writing you know
um so you must write that's the first
one and his second rule which is the one
that really impacted on me you must
finish what you write
and I'm still dealing with that all
these decades later but it did inspire
me at the time I said okay the short
story is not the greatest short story in
the history of Western literature like I
wanted to be when I started but I'm
going to finish the [ __ ] anyway and
send it out and make myself do that
heinlein's second rule and that made a
huge difference in my life and my career
the um there's a
the you've undoubtedly prepared a
[ __ ] not even a meal but uh pop culture
Buffet uh with your work uh first of
course uh in the book field and then
other media discovered it and [ __ ]
went running wild with it but your your
trendsetter and and you've written a
mythology that the world has embraced
um what is the chef eat before he makes
a meal what what do you ingest that you
don't necessarily spit out in your work
but what inspires you what do you watch
when it's time to be entertained what do
you read when it's time to be
entertained when you're not writing
when you're just a fan you started as a
fan so I imagine and I still am I I I
still
you know I
I love books
probably more than anything that was my
first love
um
as a writer and I think I'll always
return to that but I still read
voraciously of course I read a lot of
Science Fiction I read a lot of fantasy
um but not just that I I also read
mystery stories and I read history
popular history I read historical
fiction I read Classics of literature
and
um you know a lot of stuff I read a lot
of non-fiction
um journalism which is is
oh God's so depressing these days uh
what's going on in this world but I read
all of that and and I I go to movies I
own a movie theater uh I owned it before
he you too
actually that was I remember when we met
you were talking about you're like I own
a movie theater you make movies you
should come to the movie theater it's in
uh Santa Fe Santa Fe Chicago Cinema the
Jean cocktail Cinema with Santa fe's
original Art House started uh back in
the 70s and uh
you know pass through several hands
finally went under in uh 2006 and laid
vacant for seven years and I would drive
by it and I'd see the dark Ed murky and
think someone should reopen that theater
and then one day I thought hey why don't
I reopen that theater
and I did so we've we've had some fun
there
um
also you know I'm a baby boomer and we
were the first television generation so
yeah I've always watched television I
grew up on television you know the
and uh now I'm making television and
television has changed 17 times since
then but it's still you know
it's still the medium that uh really
unites us
um maybe maybe less and less because now
we have 314 channels or streamers or
cable things I mean back when I was a
kid we had I lived in New York area so I
was lucky I had like seven channels to
choose from you know to three networks
plus PBS plus all the independent
channels
um that I could watch most areas of the
country only had if they had the three
networks they were lucky some of them
only had one or two of the networks
um
now we have so much choice
I've seen that change even in even in my
my fields of science fiction fantasy
you know there was a time as recently as
the uh
80s when
if you were a science fiction fan you
could kind of read all the science
fiction being published in one one year
and you could certainly read even by the
80s you could read all the important
books you kind of knew which books were
important so you would go to Convention
and you would say oh there's a new book
out by Paul Anderson or oh Highline
that's another book and everybody would
have read it at the convention and and
you could discuss it you know what you
liked what you didn't like which writers
were better which writers were not so
good Etc they were literary disputes
going on then the old wave versus the
New Wave
you can't do that at these conventions
anymore that there's more science
fiction being published than ever before
more fantasy but people are by and large
not reading the same books so you go and
you go in excite and say hey did this
new writer did you read this book get
blank looks and then they say what they
read and you get you give them a blank
look but what's replaced that of course
is film and television and one of the
last shows to do that was Game of
Thrones and now House of the Dragon you
go to a convention and you say did you
see House of Drake yes I saw it and you
could talk about it you could say oh
that's a piece of [ __ ] or it's the
greatest thing ever made
but there's a common parlance where you
we're United around these these popular
culture uh stories and uh even ones from
you know preceding that go back a half
century now things like Star Wars and
Star Trek and
um
they unite us as a culture we talk about
them
the same way
previous generations talked about the
latest novel from Hemingway or the
latest cereal from Charles Dickens in
Victorian England
that's
the center of our culture
uh you so 79 is when you were like hey I
can quit my job and actually be like a
professional writer for a living right
so that's two years before after Star
Wars
so you see Star Wars just as a guy who
likes sci-fi what'd you think of it when
you saw it
well I
I like Star Wars quite a bit the first
one which I still call Star Wars I
haven't got used to calling it a New
Hope but uh
um
but at the same time I didn't
necessarily
think it was the great I mean Star Wars
contains a lot of ideas in it
that I've been reading
for the last 20 years out of Dune yeah
at Dune and and um
you know a lot of other Space Opera I
mean but but that was that was partly
the thrill of it I mean you saw the
Cantina scene I said I've read about
this in 50 different science fiction
stories all the aliens in the weird ass
Cantina but it was great to see it on
the screen because we hadn't really seen
it that way and done done so well
um also Star Wars
transform the science fiction field
because it made so so much money
and there was actually
kind of a false spring in the in the
world of science fiction writers and
fans around the time of Star Wars
because it's like we'd been reading this
stuff all along we knew how great it was
and now the world knew how great it was
and what did that mean that meant all of
us were going to become rich because uh
you know hey they like Star Wars now
they're going to go out and read Ray
Bradbury and they're going to read
Robert a Heinlein and they're going to
read me ooh but it didn't really work
that way they just wanted more Star Wars
um
but it did happen they gave us more Star
Wars man I mean [ __ ] what a good idea
um yeah
but it did
it did have a huge impact on the on the
field and on my my career I mean um
I published that first uh story of mine
in 1971 and I
did not write a novel right away I
continued to write uh short stories
because I didn't really have the
confidence to attempt something as major
as a novel and my short stories did
quite well I sold almost everything I
wrote and they started putting me
undercover magazines and I was nominated
for the John W Campbell Award for best
new writer I lost I was nominated for
the Hugo award for one of my stories I
lost I was nominated for the nebula
award for one of my stories I lost but I
was getting nominated every year and
then in 75 what the hell I won yeah
um
and around that time I said well I'm
gonna I'm gonna start I'm gonna write my
first novel so I wrote my first novel I
did not
interestingly enough
the way most people
in the field
wrote novels then this they would write
like three chapters an outline they'd
give it to their agent who would sell it
and then you would have a deadline to do
that I was too leery even then about my
ability to finish an entire novel
because they were kind of long and stuff
and I had all this history of you know
broken stories and so forth so
I wrote the whole book and then
delivered a finished manuscript to my
agent and said look here it is I wrote
an entire novel now go go sell it well
what had happened
um
somewhere in the middle of that was uh
was Star Wars
um
when I started writing that novel and it
took me you know a couple years
um
a first novel by a writer a new writer
which I was at the time in the 70s you'd
maybe get four thousand dollars as an
advance on it
maybe I was you know I was a Hugo nebula
loser maybe I would get five because I
was you know it was
that had been a good strategy about
publish all these short stories and then
it's not just oh here's a book by
someone you never heard of it's oh
here's a book by that famous short story
writer so you get a little more
more of that and I remember
I was almost finished I ran into Harlan
Ellison any of you know who Harlan
Ellison was he was an amazing yeah
Harlan Ellison uh was for your money one
of the best science fiction writers of
all time or just one of the best writers
of all time yes yeah he would hate being
called to Science Fiction come on stage
and disembowel you yes
but Harlan was also very encouraging to
new talents and things like that and he
he ran into me at a convention and I
said well I'm almost finished my book
and and uh he said yes and he was big
for Raiders rights you know okay and
when you finish that book you get ten
thousand dollars for it don't take a
penny less
ten thousand dollars you crazy you know
I'm hoping I'll get five you know
they'll probably just give me four my my
friend got four for his my other friend
only got three for his and he's a pretty
damn good writer I'm not gonna get no
you insist get to them you know well I
thought he was you know
speaking out of his ass there
but when I finally finished it
my agent took it and he offered it to
four Publishers and an auction got going
and I got thirty thousand dollars for it
so
suddenly it became feasible for me to
um
I think maybe I can make a living at
this thing if if that's what it's going
to be if I'm not going to get four
thousand dollars for a book that takes
me a year and I have to write but yeah I
can maybe do this so
I did when did early TV come calling I
don't mean Game of Thrones but we were
talking before earlier this evening I
was delighted to find out one of them we
all know the Twilight Zone uh I grew up
of course watching the reruns on pix the
black and white version but in the 80s
they did another version of The Twilight
Zone on CBS in the early 80s that I
would watch like religiously with my
mother Anthology series with weird ass
[ __ ] stories
George said that he wrote for it how
many episodes you write for the Twilight
five five episodes so is that the first
TV you did or did you do TV prior to
that
um that that is the first television
that I did I I had had um
some of my short stories optioned or
purchased for television shows but I had
nothing to do with it I just cashed a
check and then they they made uh
whatever they made out of it or in many
cases they failed to make anything at
all but the checks still cash so that
was okay
um
well you know I've been telling these
the good stories about uh you know me me
selling selling stories winning Awards
getting
getting an auction going on that but
there's a bad side too here I don't know
how many of you out there are
aspiring writers
um but I meet a lot of inspiring writers
and what I always tell them is it is a
profession
um
for gamblers and if you're someone who
wants security uh find a different
profession because it's it's not good
you're you know and this goes for film
and television and uh certainly for what
I was doing so I was a hot young writer
I was nominated for these Awards I won
some awards every book I wrote got
higher and higher advances I was
climbing the ladder
all the way until my fourth novel which
was a book called the Armageddon rag
which I got the biggest Advance yet and
it was supposed to be my breakthrough
book I would become a household word I
would become a bestseller and they put
out this book and it got great reviews
it was nominated for World fantasy award
and hardly anyone bought it it was a
total commercial failure and then I
discovered
that just one commercial failure
canceled like 10 years of success
suddenly nobody wanted to buy my next
novel nobody was interested oh yeah he
wrote that book and nobody bought it
um
fortunately one person who did buy it
and liked it and wanted to make a movie
of it was a television producer named
Phil deguerre and Phil had been around
TV for quite a while but he was a big
science fiction fantasy fan he was also
a big Grateful Dead fan
um and Armageddon red is a rock and roll
novel and Phil optioned that book
so he could write a screenplay
and make a feature film of it well he
did write a screenplay
he never got the film financed or made
but he I met him as a result of that
and then like a year later
Phil had he'd worked for Stephen J
Cannell and written for his shows for a
number of years he was a big producer on
baba black sheep
um and then he created his own show
Simon and Simon which was a huge hit
he created whiz kids which was not a
huge hit but was groundbreaking was the
first uh show about
teenage computer hackers before
partly anybody had a computer
and then CBS liked him and said well
Phil what do you want to do next he said
I want to bring back the Twilight Zone
oh okay yeah we owned a Twilight Zone so
Phil brought back to Twilight Zone and
he did something very unusual he didn't
just turn to professional
television writers he got a number of
them on board but he also went to a lot
of guys in the science fiction and film
thing who had never written a teleplay
in their lives and said hey you want to
you like The Twilight Zone you want to
do something for the Twilight Zone and
one of them was me
and I said
um
well I I love the Twilight Zone Rod
Sterling but I don't know how to write a
tell a play I've never even seen a
teleplay and she'll say it's easy I'll
send you some so he sent me a bunch of
teleplays and I looked at it and yeah I
think I could do this next thing I know
I'm writing a Twilight Zone script and
it came along just at the same time
because suddenly my career as a novelist
seemed to be over no one wanted to buy
that but now I had a new career so I go
out west and I'm in LA and I'm writing
uh television scripts for The Twilight
Zone and uh that was a
uh that was rare synchronicity or
something like that or but it certainly
changed my life
how long were you did you do other jobs
for TV after
uh Twilight Zone yeah I'm
I was often on involved in TV for about
10 years there oh the shows they brought
you running well I I did uh first I did
Twilight Zone for
you know second half of the first season
and all of the shortened second season
and when we were canceled I figured oh
that's it you know Twilight's almost
unusual it's not like writing for you
know TJ hooker or something like that
it's uh and every show is different it's
an anthology show
and it's all very science fiction
fantasy there wasn't a lot of that on TV
in those days
so I figured I was one and done but as
it happened ABC
was in the process of bringing in a very
hot British show been a British TV movie
called Max Headroom that they wanted to
develop [ __ ] you worked on Mac's
Headroom I did yes
and the the Brits came over who had
created Max Headroom but they never
worked on American television so ABC
said
well you need someone American
television is different you need an
experienced American showrunner and they
hired Phil and Phil brought over his
entire Twilight Zone staff
so next thing I found myself working on
a Max Headroom I did I did two Max
headrooms neither one of which you ever
saw because they were not produced which
still breaks my heart but that that I
have never seen uh
you people who out there probably don't
even know what Max Headroom was here but
it was way ahead of many people remember
Max everyone put your hands together
for those of you who are like what the
[ __ ] is it it was Matt frewer in a
plastic makeup affair right and they
would do digital effects with them where
he'd be like I I I'm here and stuff like
that and it was first it was a British
British TV show then they brought here
then he was like a he was everywhere he
was the spokesman for New Coke he was on
the cover of Time Magazine he was like
the hottest media personality in the
world
for like six months and then the show
came on and people didn't know what the
hell to make of it it was way ahead of
its time and it was like kind of cyber
Punky and took place 20 minutes into the
future when there were hundreds of TV
stations who could imagine that hundreds
of TV stations
um so it didn't last very long
but I really wish they'd made I wrote
the Christmas episode called Xmas and
that was in pre-production when the show
was canceled uh it would have been fun
if they'd made that if you get paid
right either way yeah
I got paid thank God because I hear your
heart up for cash these days
and then after that I went on a show
called Beauty and the Beast you worked
out [ __ ] Beauty and the Beast too Ron
Perlman Linda Hamilton yes that show was
huge that was uh we did that for three
years I wrote 13 scripts for that
and you know there's a lot would be very
much up your alley the more I think
about that show man was that now at that
point where you're like Jesus Christ
I've reached the top of the mountain
it'll never be better than this
or did you have ambition did you know
there was more no I I had ambition I
wanted I did want the top of the
mountain I guess
when you work in television
um I mean it's very different than books
when you write a book it's just you and
the blank page
um and you're everything television or
film is a collaborative medium and you
always have people
above you uh give me your notes giving
you suggestions other writers in the
writer's room the showrunner if you're
on a show where you're a showrunner have
a showrunner uh at the studio the
network the sponsors the the sensors
they're all weighing in and you know I
dealt with it that's the job is I'm sure
most of you have bosses and all that but
I was coming from a world of where I was
the boss when I read a novel there's
there's you know I have editors but it's
mostly me
so at a certain point in this uh
process of working for these shows the
ambition grew in me to be uh
the showrunner myself to have my own
show that I would create not I mean Rod
Sterling created a Twilight Zone
beauty and beast was created by Ron
koslow Max Headroom head to Brits and
then Phil de geaire
um I I wanted my own show so
and I had climbed I on all these shows
that I've been I'd climbed the ladder I
started as a when I was first hired on
Twilight Zone on staff they my title was
staff writer
now you know that that's the lowest
title you can possibly have because it's
the only one that has the word writer in
it after that you become a story editor
and an executive story editor and
co-producer oh you got the p word
um producer very uh very important word
I still remember when I was made it was
on Beauty and the Beast that I was made
co-producer
and I remember
saying who is the other co-producer and
then no you're you're the only
co-producer I can't be a co-producer
unless there's another co-producer well
no not in television speak code just
means you know you're not quite as good
as a producer executive means you're a
little better so you know there's little
words here so I went from being a
co-producer to a producer and all that
but at the end of this thing
beauty and beast was canceled before I
could become a showrunner but then I
went into development and for the next
five years I wrote feature films I wrote
television Pilots I had one television
pilot film but not picked up a series I
had a number that they love it they love
it but they didn't make it
and I made a lot of money but it was
emotionally too unsatisfying I
discovered that I needed uh
I guess the Applause I needed no matter
what they paid me spending a year of my
life creating a television show and
writing episodes of it and nobody ever
sees it except four guys in the room it
was so frustrating you know they was
like my stillborn children do you have
stillborn children do you have movies
that you never got to know I have a list
of [ __ ] that I've announced and never
done hmm
it happens I mean honestly it's like
it's a miracle you can get anything you
know it's a miracle you can get anything
[ __ ] made let alone all the things
you talk about wanting to do and
oftentimes like my [ __ ] has to be
manifested by me throwing my hat over
the wall and talking about it years
before it happens like there's a thing
and we're going to do it and the more
you talk about it the more real it
becomes and that's how I proceed so yeah
there's but there's some stuff that is
never
seen the light of day it happens yeah
so um you know in the in the 90s I
after 10 you know 10 years in television
and film I went back and started writing
what became Game of Thrones
that when it happened so after TV you're
like you know what sort of after a
little overlapping uh you know I was
doing TV but I was also starting to
write this book and I had no deadline I
had no contract I was just writing it in
my own time so I actually began Game of
Thrones in 91 and then one of my Pilots
got picked up so I put aside for a
couple years but when I came back to it
it was still very fresh so
why uh why dragons
yes Breakers are cool
I like dragons
um
I actually
you know you go back to the early
beginnings and and you wonder about that
um
there was a very early stage
of uh me writing Game of Thrones
where I thought I would not have literal
dragons I would have you know we had the
heraldry we had you know lions and
direwolves and all that and I would have
one house I would have to drag against
the targaryens and I was playing with
the idea that maybe you know this is my
science fiction
idea coming you know that maybe the
targaryens had some kind of
psionic power like they were like
pyromancers and they could manifest
blasts of flame mentally like in
Firestarter or something like that and
that's why they were identified with
Dragons but there would be no Little
Dragons and I remember I showed it to a
friend of mine a wonderful fantasy
writer loot in Chicago Phyllis
eisenstein she read the chapters and you
have to have the dragons you can't just
do it without the dragons and she made a
good case so I did it sadly Phyllis
Phyllis died a couple years ago but she
was a very talented writer who
deserve more attention than she ever got
but her Legacy she gave you a fantastic
[ __ ] note man she did yes that was a
good note yeah
that was a good note what uh
um I would imagine like Jason Muse uh
when he was trying to get me to watch
Game of Thrones he was talking about you
have to watch it it's historical
do you get people who think that [ __ ]
actually happened
because you're so rich with detail that
like I've heard the expression people
like well back in Game of Throne days
and it's like that never [ __ ]
happened
well I I do read a lot of history and
historical fiction and a lot of the
stuff in uh particularly Game of Thrones
is uh based Loosely on things that
happen in real history but I I I've
never actually written historical
fiction
beyond that story about the Russia
Finnish war of 1808
um because it was such a hit because you
know what happens in historical fiction
and I I like to surprise my readers and
also sometimes the things that really
happened are not satisfying I can figure
a better end or a better twist but I I
take that so Game of Thrones
is based to a great degree on the wars
of the roses and the new show has the
dragon is based on a period in English
History called the Anarchy but I changed
the names I I dial it up to 11 or 311.
and I throw in Dragons and direwolves
and
other things
um
but history does figure into the uh
let's figure into the mix
um
and it's a it's not a science it's an
art as to
where you draw the line you know I
sometimes I get people reviewing the
books who want something to be different
or they want something
um that's not there or they want
something that is there it should be
taken out
and I say no I'm basing this on history
and I'm trying to stay kind of true in
it well you have dragons if you have
dragons you could change everything else
too why can't people fly just by farting
you have dragons
well I don't consider that I'm writing
that one down that's [ __ ]
criticism but yes uh so uh yeah
um
the when you were when you start you put
out the first book yes how do you know
when your fan base begins were there
fans from the first book or was it not
until another book where you were able
to connect the dots like oh they're
following along closely well there were
there were readers from the first book
um
but not huge numbers of them I mean Game
of Thrones did well when it was Ish but
it didn't do great it was you know uh
there were a lot of fantasy books
um
I think Bantam my publisher wanted to be
bigger but it didn't make any best
seller lists but it you know it's well
reviewed people read it but the
important thing was the trend because
when the second book came out it did
better and I did make a bestseller list
like number 13 for one week and then
when the third book came out
um suddenly I was number six and I was
on the list for five weeks
so the word of mouth is still the best
advertising you can have it's nice if
you have promotion and they send you on
book tours and you know big ads and
newspapers but nothing replaces the uh
the word of mouth at least in the old
days now I know we have the internet as
I say I'm very old I haven't got used to
this interwebby thing yet but maybe
that's now more important than Word of
Mouth even I it's hard to say it's so
such a weird world to me out there but
it it built it built and that was
important too
I remember uh of course when the show
had if you have a television show
and it's a successful television show
then all bets are are off then once the
television show hit the books were
already
you know number one best sellers but
then they just moved on to the list for
a decade all of them and they stayed
there
um because of the power of uh of
Television it is the dominant
um you know
culture of our age popular culture is
the thing that everybody's watching
everybody's talking about and it reaches
millions and millions and millions of
people not just here in the United
States but all around the world
the um this this gross money question
but we all know that TV pays very well
particularly with HBO blows up it
becomes a huge hit and stuff but
like could I have to imagine that you
could live off the book money alone for
a thousand lifetimes by this point if
the books continue to be on the best
seller list you continue to make money
from all the books correct that is
correct
and that's why I can buy movie theaters
and trains tell them about your [ __ ]
trains and they only own a third of the
train
it's a little line called the the Santa
Fe Southern that was defunct it runs for
18 miles and it was sort of defunct but
me and two Partners bought it and we
were restoring it we call it Sky Railway
now and it runs uh if you're ever in
Santa Fe that's one of the things you
have to do take a ride on the sky
Railway where we uh
sometimes the train is held up by
Outlaws occasionally there's a murder on
it and the passengers have to decide who
killed they're really selling it man
yeah it's why isn't one of them like a
wolf and one's a dragon yes the the
locomotives yeah locomotives we uh we
painted them we hired a graffiti artist
to uh paint them but that's a lot of fun
actually you know TV does pay well you
know certainly
but
with the first book
you know when I got my first deal with
HBO I actually made more money from the
books the books all started selling and
selling and uh that's all just me and
Random House HBO doesn't have part of
that so it was more money coming in from
the books than coming in from TV but and
I have to imagine too as the guy died in
the war writer the kid who started
writing first short stories and then
novels that money feels even more
satisfying because at your heart you've
done a lot of things but would you
consider yourself ultimately a novelist
at heart or a writer at heart
which is like you know Christian
Catholic yeah I I don't know I think I
consider myself a Storyteller that's
that's a good word it depends on
you know I can tell stories in many
different
um media
um teleplay
uh script film script um or you know
comic books too you've done wild cards
comic books on superhero universe as
well we do yes mostly I've edited wild
cards but I've written for it too that's
been going even longer than Game of
Thrones and we hope we'll have a wild
cards TV show on soon but
yeah it's very hard always talking about
film projects and television projects
because you never know if they're
actually going to get on or not it just
seems so promising and exciting and then
something someone changes or
they put it before a focus group or
don't like it or and and yeah then it
doesn't get made at all so I hesitate to
talk about
forthcoming projects that I don't know
are going to be real but there are I'm
always juggling like eight different
projects here I mean we're doing more
successor shows to Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon we're developing a
wild card show uh dark winds is um
executive producer on that that's on
yeah
that's on AMC we're working on the
second second season of that now
um and there's a movie based on one of
my old short stories that's uh going to
be shooting in Poland in about a week so
uh in the Lost lands with uh
um Mila Jovovich and Dave Batista so
let's go you're finally on your way
George
yay
that letter that they put that they
published to viewers in Marvel back in
the day Fantastic Four about Fantastic
Four number 17.
um you're listed as George R Martin
where'd that second R come from
I was at Catholic and uh is that your
confirmation name it is no oh my God I'm
Kevin Patrick Thomas Smith
yeah so wait you're a Catholic kid too
well I was I I can't say no wonder all
those [ __ ] died at the Red
Wedding man that is so [ __ ] Catholic
um yeah I used to be one as well why'd
you leave
I had I had oddly enough it was a very
liberal Pope and Pope John the 23rd who
was a good Pope I think and who convened
the Vatican II Council
and they made a
many changes
which were good they introduced the mass
that didn't have to be in Latin and
things like that turned the priest
around right
um
but Catholics I don't know how many of
you are Catholics we I had to go to
catechism and learn about uh venial sins
and Mortal sins and
um of course you could go to confession
and you have all your sins forgiven and
then you were then you were good but um
if you like died with sins on your soul
then you went to
um it depended if there were venial sins
as they called them then you just had to
go to Purgatory for you know 800 years
or something like that that's what I was
I was aiming for Purgatory right but if
you died before going to confession
would a mortal sin on your soul you
burned in Hell forever there was no
getting around that
and there were a number of mortal sins
including you know the big ones that
you'd think like murder and stuff like
that but there was also eating meat on
Friday
was a mortal sin until
Vatican II
and Vatican II
took it off the list of mortal sins
which was good but it also produced in
me at the age of 13 or something a
crisis of Faith where I'm saying let me
get this straight
if I had a cheeseburger last Friday I
will burn in hell forever
if I have a cheeseburger this Friday I'm
good
ah that just made me think no I I can't
believe this stuff anymore now you know
how we all feel about legal weed
[Laughter]
um what made you stop uh
um I made Dogma oh yes did that get you
excommunicated well
pretty nearly yeah I just by the time I
was done with that movie I was like oh I
get it and I just kind of moved on I
like to tell people like I've stopped
practicing because I got it down to a
science
um I want to tell these cats uh first
off we're going to be wrapping up soon
how amazing is [ __ ] George Ben kicks
[Music]
thank you guys I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell them a Charming story
that you told me and you can uh jump in
anytime number one I
we don't know each other super well but
the highest compliment I could [ __ ]
pay you is the amount that I've shut up
all [ __ ] night long the amount of
times I put the mic down and [ __ ] oh my
god
um the um you told me the story in new
chatel we we uh met at the new chatel
film festival in Switzerland years ago
um he told me this really wonderful
story about when you were you know when
Game of Thrones first came out uh the
books you would have signings and tell
them 10 people will show up yeah yeah if
if uh if that
um
yeah I'd been remember I I had that 10
years in Hollywood so I I had my early
novels
but then I'd been away from writing
novels for 10 years so when Game of
Thrones coming out my publisher sends me
on a uh
book tour very small book tour I went to
like three cities in Texas couple other
places
so and they didn't know how many people
were going to show up because I was sort
of uh well he's been away he hasn't had
a book for a while so um I I started in
Houston where about 10 people showed up
for the signing
and then I went to Austin Well Austin
has a big science fiction community and
I had friends there so maybe I had like
20 people showing up in Austin
and then I went to the Dallas area but
not actually Dallas was a place called
Denton Texas North one of my favorite
cities in the world is college town big
college that's right outside Dallas
so we pull in they give you um every
when you're on book tour every time you
come you have a an escort a local guy
who drives you around so my escort is
driving me to this uh I think it was a
Barnes and Noble or something big
Superstore in Denton Texas huge parking
lot
um
and there's no parking spaces the entire
lot is full there's all these people
getting out of their cars and they're
swarming into the theater or into the
bookstore and I'm thinking holy [ __ ]
this book is really successful look at
all these people coming in for for My
Autograph it's going to be so exciting
here I'm going to have all these people
um fortunately we we found a parking
space because my uh
my escort had a bum leg and a handicap
sticker so we were able to park near the
near the store and I go in to find my
huge crowds of people
and uh it turns out that there were two
signings in the store that day
in the front of the store I was signing
and I had 10 people
in the back of the store Clifford the
Big Red Dog was signing
now the way Clifford goes on tour
is they have a big Clifford costume that
they mail from store to store
and whoever is the most recent or Junior
employee at the store has to put it on
because I don't think any of the stores
washed the costume so you may be the
47th Clifford to Don your particular
costume and then they have a giant red
ink pad and you know that one of the
hands is uh
he puts his hand in the ink pad
and then he smashes the book and you get
a paw print and all of your Clifford
books here so
so I was crushed by
Clifford the Big Red Dog
um and that's where direwolves came from
the uh one of my favorite stories that
you told me of uh your success as a
writer improving the crowds was uh
George was talking about like uh you
know he'd done Sonics 10 20 people the
books at once Game of Thrones hit HBO
Max obviously the books reach more
people the crowds get bigger George
Watson watches It Go from tens of people
to hundreds of people showing up for a
book signing to I guess thousands in
Poland was that it yeah the hundreds of
people were
well good I mean when I reached the
stage where hundreds of people were
showing up for me signing I said this is
this is great I finally made it oh look
hundreds of people
but I didn't stop to think that it would
I
would continue to grow and when the
hundreds become thousands
yeah that's that's hard uh what what
Kevin is talking about is I they sent me
overseas to Poland and Slovenia to do
some signings and I had additions in
both of these books and both of these
countries and uh
I had two signings in Poland where like
thousands of people showed up
and I got through those and then I had a
one one signing in a small city in
Slovenia
where it was only like 50 100 people and
that was good and then I had a second
signing at a different city in Slovenia
which was insane it was bigger than
Poland it was it was I don't know we
completely filled the bookstore I was on
the second floor and there were people
they were bussing people in from Croatia
uh and and the line went back and forth
through all the aisles of the second
floor and then down the staircase
through all the aisles of the first
floor then out onto the street and uh
down down the block and
that signing almost killed me also that
was at a stage
see now if
if I sign a book now I just scroll my
illegible signature but in in those days
I was doing
other things like signing three books
and saying well I'll personally inscribe
one
um I don't do that anymore because I
can't but uh in those days I was doing
that and I would ask the people like an
American signing to to write their name
on a Post-It note
and then I could say you know to to Fred
to Fred you know and I would describe it
but they don't have Post-it notes in
Slovenia so I was getting little scraps
of toilet paper or tissue or any kind of
thing and also
they don't have vowels in Slovenia so
I'm saying oh I I would I would try to
inscribe the name and you have
you have only put three K's in my name I
have I have four K's I'm gonna have to
put in another k
um yeah so that was uh four people
fainted during that signing because the
store was not air-conditioned and it was
summer so that was that was quite a
challenging signing but there was one
a number of years after that I was a
guest of at the Guadalajara book fair in
in Guadalajara Mexico which uh
is the biggest book fair in in the
Americas
um
very large a lot of people showing up
and by then I I knew I said oh I'm going
to sign one book just one book just the
signature no no
Post-it notes no personal inscriptions
but I took one of my assistants with me
and she's wonderful she's not here the
assistant who's with me is Sid and it
wasn't her so don't blame her but I do
love my other assistant and she spoke
she was Hispanic and she flew spoke
fluent Spanish
and um
I thought that was a good idea because
we were going to Mexico
so and I kept that I'm signing I said
600 people 600 people no more than that
I can do that in an hour 600 people I
will write my name
and no inscriptions and then it'll be
done so put someone at the end of the
line capitalist 600 people and they did
that they were very well organized they
kept the line unfortunately
the second person in line
said can I give him a hug and my
assistant said yes
so 598 hugs later
I I was finally because you can't hug
one person and not hug everybody else in
line
so I don't do hugs anymore guys I'm
sorry you're all very cute but no
um and that's why you kill so many
characters in Game of Thrones because
those [ __ ] hugs
the uh I remember you told me the story
of uh you were doing a signing and went
so [ __ ] long this is when you were
doing inscriptions oh yeah so you would
alternate between two inscriptions yes I
I had a certain phrases I used when I
was still inscribing you know
um best wishes of course is a standard
one warm regards is another one
occasionally I would write
um keep your sword sharp or winter is
coming you know kind of things and that
that was at that one in in Slovenia yeah
where I at a certain point in like the
eighth hour of signing I looked down and
I was writing wishes is coming
best best Winters hahaha
fortunately
many of them had only limited English so
they didn't know what the hell I had
written in their books
um
now you're going to broadcast this I'm
going to get in trouble my Slovenian
fans are going to come after you you
should have made me tell them look at
the book and be like wishes is coming
what the [ __ ]
uh before we let you get out of here uh
the guy who introduced me uh or and
begged me I was talking about in the
intro uh to watch Game of Thrones Jason
Muse like died in the wall
fan he uh we do a podcast that just
dropped today called Father's Day and
the idea of the podcast is Jay just
found out him and his wife Jordan are
about to have their second child
so
they're not here don't applaud for them
no you get a blob and they're wonderful
people so Jason has been trying to
figure out what to name
the kid
and you have come up with amazing
[ __ ] names
I don't know you want to give me that
responsibility
I think I'm ready to put his new child's
life on the line and say you may name it
George
well I could play it safe and say Jon
Snow he could get away with a John right
aegon you want to go with aegon
aegon the Conqueror
egg on the Conqueror Muse
[Laughter]
that'll work the kid will have a lot to
live up to that's for day I'm sure
um everyone uh here tonight I'm sure
appreciates the journey that you took us
on here in this room and I'm sure
everyone in this room tonight
appreciates the journey that you've
taken us on uh with your work over the
years
um
[Music]
[Applause]
and I think I probably speak for
everybody in the room who's from the uh
from the great state of New Jersey when
I say thank you for giving us
something to be proud of all the state
[ __ ] had was Clerks
[Laughter]
and bar pies the Jersey bar pie
absolutely right
and Atlantic City you're all right it
had a few [ __ ] things
but it's the boss the boss yeah I don't
know who he is but still uh yes of
course we've had Bruce Springsteen we've
had Bon Jovi but honestly think about it
like Game of Thrones is has permeated
the entire or not just culture but the
planet everybody knows this [ __ ] show
and it's secret Origins lie in the heart
of a kid from Bayonne New Jersey
thank you for taking us on that Journey
ladies and gentlemen give it up for the
one the only George RR Martin
thank you guys
take your time take your time uh kids uh
just sit Ty for a sec let us like uh
clear George out and stuff like that
give it up for George
's gone how [ __ ] awesome was that
uh more of that in this life kids less
than [ __ ] everything else uh thank
you thank you for being here thanks for
making it possible
um I there's
rumors that we may be doing something
similar uh to this in December with the
Russo brothers so pay attention uh to
the website smogcastlecinemas.com we'll
let you know and then in the new year I
reached out to a few uh director friends
of mine and uh they're going to be
coming to join us here Zack Snyder is
going to come bring Justice League here
he's never shown in the theater that's
gonna be great Jason reitman's going to
come and show something uh James Gunn
said that he's going to come as well
with guardians so we got some cool [ __ ]
coming to our uh Little Spa Castle
Cinemas here you all have a good time
tonight kids
thank you so much for being part of the
dream uh do me a favor as you uh head
out like the kids who work here to high
school kids and whatnot uh who tend to
the the concession stand and stuff uh
you know hit the tip jar if you can on
the way out uh otherwise I'm gonna have
to put a hundred dollars in there
tonight and [ __ ]
uh the kids here are absolutely [ __ ]
wonderful it's been the UN unheralded
part of this whole [ __ ] experience
when we bought the theater as me and
Ernie and Ashley and Jeff and uh Tony
um you know there was we weren't
thinking about the people who'd be
working here we were thinking oh my God
we're going to buy the theaters gonna
we're gonna have so much fun and in
picking up the theater we got to meet
all the kids that work here and when I
say I call everyone kids and [ __ ] except
Tim he's older than me but generally
speaking I'm always like the kids the
kids who work here are [ __ ] kids some
of them are in high school which is so
[ __ ] Charming to me uh to no end and
stuff and um I've uh I've fallen in love
with all of them which sounds weird I
shouldn't say that they're kids
but um you know I I my right upstairs is
is my apartment so I I live upstairs and
then kind of come down here to do shows
and stuff and go back upstairs so
periodically when I'm not off doing the
tour and I'm back here I'm up there just
bombing around and I will run out of
[ __ ] like oh my God I have no water and
I'm like wait a second they have water
downstairs
and so like in my pajamas and robe like
my back stairs come down behind the
concessions counter so periodically I
just pop out like Kramer and [ __ ]
and go grab water and you know kids like
what the [ __ ] man
I'm sorry I gotta warn you next time
I'll give a shout and [ __ ] so I grab my
water and go back upstairs and
periodically people are like buying [ __ ]
and whatnot I'm like hi welcome to Spa
Castle Cinemas and [ __ ] you want me to
enjoy your movie for you you know
so the other day I [ __ ] uh I was
upstairs and uh I came down and uh you
know opened the door and you know now I
lean into it open the door so [ __ ]
fast briskly and pop out and [ __ ] and
there was a kid who I hadn't seen before
was like holy [ __ ]
and I was like oh man I'm sorry I should
have worn it like no everyone else
warned me already
I was like what do you mean it's like
everyone else that works here talks
about how you just come out of the walls
and [ __ ] like that
I was like get out of here and said yeah
they got a nickname for you I said what
they're like they call you The Phantom
so look out for my kids man they're good
kids uh Ernie O'Donnell ladies and
gentlemen made sure that uh this evening
went super smooth give it up for Ernie
uh
for those uh who were watching and home
streaming or if anybody wants to go home
and watch this when it's all done
because we shot the whole thing we can
only do that because of Josh Roush give
it up for Josh everybody
um and uh she got him here in one piece
and then was you know usually when
you're dealing with folks you deal with
their people and it's a blessing when
their people are really cool to to deal
with George's person said give it up for
Sid everybody
and of course like you know the dude's
got a zillion things to do but he took
the time uh to come down here which
means that I'm gonna have to go to his
[ __ ] movie theater and [ __ ]
which will be an absolute pleasure man
uh give it up for the great George RR
and that's it for stop
you for being here for Curious George I
love you all good night
[Applause]